what the hell you smoking in here
smoking none of that my good officer I
believe the term you're looking for is
conjuring cut the [ __ ] and give me your
license and registration oh dear
is there something we've done wrong
traversing this dark Avenue of the night
you were going 70 on a side street and
judging by the look of things where are
we
what's that simply an illusion are you
gonna give me your license and
registration or am I gonna give you a
citation very well very well sir
ha
here we are magicians license I don't
have time for the book again cute how
much your registration for that trick
I'll need the help of my lovely
assistant
okay on account of your speed and the
smoke I'm gonna have to give you a
sobriety test please step out of the car
and escape act hey
half of this if the right to remain
silent anything you say can and will be
used against you in a court of law
have the right to an attorney if you
can't afford one one will be a sign to
you okay I'm sorry I'm sorry
look surely two gentlemen such as
ourselves can work out an agreement here
don't take this the wrong way but the
transvestite will do anything man
sir get out of the vehicle keep your
hands where I can see them
what is all this [ __ ] we have a gig
tomorrow not anymore you doctor Hey
Shazam what do you think of that freeze
he'll looking for this
step right up and see the show of a
lifetime you that's right you experience
the world okay man right here man right
you're gonna smoke in your face and then
you fell have you wiped out you wipe out
so good my shift
you